hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapter 15 of his work leviathan
thomas hobbes is going to set out the
other
laws of nature what are the other laws
well
those in addition to the first and
second laws of nature that he detailed
in the previous
chapter as it turns out by my count
there's
about 14 entirely at a certain point in
the text he just stops
numbering them and goes on and tells us
there's another and another
and we can tally them up and and you
know put them into this this sort of
arrangement
now these are incredibly important
for understanding hobbes's perspective
not only on what we can call social and
political philosophy how things
have to be arranged within society but
also for
moral philosophy or ethics and he will
indeed
claim that his treatment of this
is the true and only moral philosophy
which
interesting claim we'll talk about
elsewhere it has some important
implications for what ought to be taught
in the schools
we should remind ourselves from chapter
14 what a law
of nature is so he tells us that it's a
precept or general rule found out by
reason by which a person is forbidden to
do that which is describe destructive of
their life or taketh away the means of
preserving the same
and to omit that leave that out by which
he thinks it may
well be best preserved and so these are
you know laws that we can derive through
our rational activity
figuring out what is going to conduce to
staying alive and
enjoying a decent life and there's a few
other aspects of the laws of nature
before we look at the specifics of them
that we should highlight
because he tells us these in chapter 15
and they are quite important so the
first
bit is that he says that they oblige
in what he calls in foro interno
right so what does that mean it means
that they they
are obligatory on us they bind to a
desire that they should take
place and then he contrasts that to
infor
external that is to putting them in act
they don't always
oblige us in that way they don't they're
not effective in the sense of
oh we realize them and we automatically
start acting that way
we need other things to make sure that
we're actually going to follow them
so that that's an important thing we can
recognize the laws
that doesn't mean that we're always
going to automatically
do what they they require us to do or
forbid us to to do right the other thing
that he says
that's really interesting right after
that though he says the laws of nature
are
immutable and eternal
so they don't exist you could say in the
state of nature or at least they're not
recognized in the state of nature
and yet they have a unchangeable that's
what immutable is
and eternal existence
presumably if there were other rational
beings besides humans
these laws of nature would be binding
upon them as well and hobbes does
believe
that there is a god so you know they
could exist in in god's mind and be
eternal in that way
but the point here is that they're not
going to change and he says
why injustice ingratitude arrogance
pride iniquity exception of persons and
the rest
can never be made lawful for it can
never be
that war shall preserve life and peace
destroy it so this goes back to the
nature of laws of of nature which is
that
they tell us how to preserve our
own life and you could say human life
more
generally since they're binding on other
people now there's there's another
point to this he brought up all these
things like injustice in gratitude
arrogance
pride those are what we call vices and
he tells us
that the science of virtue and vice is
moral philosophy
therefore the true doctrine of the laws
of nature is the true
moral philosophy all of these laws
are not only what we could call
deontological rules
obey these they also express a certain
engagement with
what we traditionally call virtue ethics
so
hobbes is at least framing these in
terms of a familiar language of virtue
and vice so those are important traits
let's look at the laws themselves now
the third law which is very short he
gives a very long
discussion too much of which we're going
to skip over about the nature of justice
and injustice
so the third law is simply we should
perform the covenants
that we have made if we want to
have a viable society in which
you know we we can fulfill the first two
laws
then we actually have to follow through
on our commitments and
uh hobbs says that in this law of nature
consists of the fountain
and original of justice where no
covenant
has proceeded no right has been
transferred and everybody has right to
everything
but once we actually have a covenant
made to break it
is unjust and so the definition of
injustice is no other than the
non-performance of covenant
and whatsoever is not unjust is
just and so there you know there's a lot
of discussion about why people do the
wrong thing
can you be wicked and be successful
what justice and injustice means when we
use them to talk about human beings
actions
and all of those sorts of things so but
we're going to skip over that
and not worry too much about that but
what we have here is a rule a law of
nature that says
once you've made an agreement you have
to follow through on it that
is what it means to be just to break
them
is unjust the fourth law of nature
has to do with gratitude the way that
that hobbes frames it
is a person who receiveth benefit from
another of mere grace endeavor
that he which giveth it shall have no
reasonable cause to repent
him of his good will why because nobody
gives
but with intention of good to himself
because gift is voluntary
and all that so he's saying if people
are good to you and they give you
something without requiring something
from you
don't make it bad for them you know
don't complain about the gift that you
got for example
don't uh do bad things to them so that
they say why did i
help this person out right and he calls
that
gratitude that's that's a virtue for
hobbes uh
as a opposed to ingratitude which
is a vice the fifth law of nature which
he calls
complete essence uh kind of an
old-fashioned word
for getting along is runs like this
every person should strive
to accommodate himself to the rest
he says we can consider there is in
human beings happness to society a
diversity of nature
rising from diversity of affections not
unlike to that which we see in stones
brought together for building an
edifice the stone which by the asperity
the roughness and irregularity of figure
takes more room from others than itself
fills and for the hardness cannot be
easily made plain
and thereby hindereth the building is by
the builders castaway is unprofitable
and troublesome so don't be that that
stone that doesn't fit in be you know
be willing to adapt yourself to
the society of others that is
a law of nature once again a general
rule that we can
follow with number six we get to another
important aspect of life
and he says upon caution of a future
time
a man ought to pardon the offenses past
of them that repenting
desire it pardon is nothing but the
granting of peace
so if somebody does something wrong and
they
say they're sorry and they maybe make
amends or something like that you should
pardon those offenses and not demand
punishment or redress or
retribution or as he's going to talk
about in the next one revenge
right that helps to preserve a viable
relationship and society
number seven we could talk about his
rational punishment
he actually frames it like this in
revenges that is retribution of evil for
evil
men look not at the greatness of the
evil past but the greatness of the good
to follow and
what he's actually proposing here is
a that not that people don't get
punished but that they're punished
in order to deter others from engaging
in that action and to keep them from
engaging in it as well
he says uh we are forbidden to inflict
punishment with any other design
than for correction of the offender or
direction of others
so he's he's saying don't just try to
you know
attain justice for the victims or
something like that the victims are gone
or dead or something like that or or
perhaps
you you know if they're living you could
redress it in that way but
what we're really looking at is a much
more utilitarian approach where we say
well
how are we going to keep this person
from doing this in the future
how are we going to keep others from
doing this sort of thing
number eight is another quite
interesting
one he says that
because all signs of hatred or contempt
provoke to fight
we have this law of nature that no
person by deed
word countenance or gesture declare
hatred or
contempt of another the breach of which
law is con
commonly called kantumli now we don't
use that word contumely
right are you a contempl contumlius
person no
we call somebody a jerk or an a-hole or
something like that right
and he's saying don't display hatred
which is a
more active thing and don't display
contempt where you don't care about the
person
at all don't display this in words don't
display it in gestures don't display it
in
actions don't display it in countenance
which is
your facial expression right
so that's that's an important one
closely related to this number nine uh
he he says every person should
acknowledge
others for their equal by nature and
this is
going against our natural tendency to
think that we're better than everybody
else
the breach of this precept he says is
pride
thinking that we're better acting as if
we're better than others so we're
supposed to acknowledge
others as being on the same level
as us number 10 is closely related he
says
on this law dependeth another that at
the entrance into conditions of peace
no person required to reserve to
themselves any right
which they're not content should be
reserved to every one of the rest so if
i want to say that it's okay for me
to play my music loud i've got to be
cool with other people playing their
music loud and i'm being a jerk
i'm being i'm breaking the law of nature
if i'm saying i'm the exception
i get to do that thing i i should occupy
a position
of privilege or be you know
better than everybody else so that
that's an important one
and then we get to things that have to
do with conflicts
themselves so the the
the next one he says if a person be
trusted to judge between
other people it's a precept of the law
of nature that they deal equally
between them without that the
controversies of people cannot be
determined other than war so
if you can't actually rely on a
just arbitration then
it makes sense it's rational just to go
into conflict right
and this this leads to all sorts of
problems so he says
that the person who's partial in
judgment
doth what in him lies to deter people
from the use of judges
and is the cause of war so
the observance of this law is called
equity
and the violation exception of
persons or as we would call it
partiality or corruption
we might even say
number 12 also has to do with justice in
some respect he says
things that cannot be divided should be
enjoyed in common if it can be
think about like a park right you can
have your little portion of a park or
you know be at a campsite
but really we should allow everybody to
be able to use the park
and you're not going to divide it up
into you know permanent slots for
for everybody so they should be enjoyed
in common if it can be and if the
quantity of the thing permit without
stint
otherwise proportionably to the number
of them that have right so
you can't be in the park occupying a
space the entire time
you've got to have some you know you can
leave it for other people too right
or if we're talking about common
reserves of say fish or
something like that you can't fish out
all the fish for
for just yourself or you know forests
things along
those lines the uh 13th one
he tells us that here here again we're
dealing with conflict
all people that mediate peace should be
allowed
safe conduct isn't that an interesting
idea
anybody who is involved in the process
of trying to resolve
conflict don't go after them why does
hobbs have to make this a rule
presumably because it was something that
was being violated quite frequently in
his society
remember that he lived through the
english civil war and had to flee it for
for france finally uh number 14
uh and this kind of goes back to the
beginning again
says it's the law of nature that those
who are at
controversy submit their right to the
judgment of an arbitrator
why instead of like deciding things for
ourself
or just trying to impose ourselves on
the other person
we should go through some sort of formal
process
in which somebody else decides now of
course that means that
number 11 has to be in in force right we
have to have an arbitrator who's going
to judge fairly
but this is something that that allows
us to not
be in a state of war with other people
he tells us that there's other things
that we could talk about
for example drunkenness and other parts
of intemperance and he says these may be
reckoned among those things that the law
of nature has
forbidden but they're not necessary to
be mentioned nor pertinent enough to
this place so this is not necessarily a
totally exhaustive list you have to
apply some common sense
to it as well and these
are you know if you put them together
with the first two laws of nature
a pretty you know long and consistent
set
covering the way a person ought to
reason and then the way a person ought
to behave
in a society where there's some
reasonable expectation
that other people will follow these as
well
so that you can live a secure and
more enjoyable life
you